Fox and Friends Weekend co-host with the
rich Sports background will Gaine joins
us now well he's not exaggerating if he
had a great season he was going to get a
four-year 100 million dollar contract
from somebody right
yeah from somebody probably from the
Nets if not he was going to be traded he
says this scared other teams off from
trading for him Brian there were options
he said but not many why because the
stigma that had been created The
Narrative the story about Kyrie Irving
then became oh well he's a bad teammate
he's unwilling to do what it takes to be
available for his team and the truth is
Brian that's like sort of the most
benign thing that was said about people
now not just NBA stars but people that
chose not to be vaccinated you're a
terrible person Society you're hurting
others you're killing your neighbor this
is all that was said for anyone that
chose not to get unvaccinated and let's
just to remain unvaccident just be clear
Brian the only reason for a mandate the
only reason that Kyrie couldn't play the
only reason the teachers and military
personnel uh were lost their job
Hospital workers lost their job was
because the vaccine was supposed to stop
transmission and we know that is false I
mean Anthony fauci just tested positive
this summer after four shots Anthony
Orla the Pfizer CEO just tested positive
for the second time in two months
despite four shots of covet Brian it
doesn't stop transmission and we use
people like Kyrie and more importantly
average Americans out there as
scapegoats for our society's problem and
yank their jobs yanked their money and
honestly yanked their reputation away
from them remember the military's been
gutted because of it cops have been
fired because of it nurses have been
told to get out because of its Sloan
Kettering and others uh and in different
cities so when we bring up Kyrie Irving
we're bringing up an example of a guy
who had a job that just said I want to
get it you're not going to tell me what
to do with my body I'm in great shape I
get it I read about it and he's right it
almost destroyed a huge team that might
never be the same because of him Kevin
Durant one of the best players in the
league said you know I can't do this
alone when he finally did play on away
games it was okay but at the end he
wanted to be traded it could have blew
up a franchise to the value of that
franchise big time but they're all back
yeah and people put that on Kyrie
everything you just described they said
well just get the shot man just get the
shot I mean how how intrusive how how
totally ignorant of privacy is that type
of response that hey man just make this
medical decision for everybody else even
though it doesn't do anything for
everybody else and I like that you say
this Brian because it's so important
look it is a lot to give up 100 million
dollars but Kyrie's gonna be okay he has
and will make millions and millions more
it's a lot and not you have to ask how
many of us out there would go 100
million shot or no shot so you've got to
give Kyrie credit for his principal but
there are average Americans out there
that gave up 100 of their income gave up
their job on principle and we as a
society look not you not me but as a
society we tolerated this this really
this this ugly instinct to scapegoat
others right uh while variants rolled
out and this and the vaccine as you
mentioned was not effective against it
and gradually the president just says oh
by the way pandemic's over as slip shot
as he said you better go get this
vaccine or else this is a pandemic of
the unvaccinated it was just so many
wrong moves uh that's was uh best
example there hey will I'll see you soon
I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now